So a few years ago, my eyes were opened to the dark side of the construction industry.
In 2006, young Qatari students took me to go and see the migrant worker camps.
And since then I've followed the unfolding issue of worker rights.
In the last six months, more than 300 skyscrapers in the UAE have been put on hold or canceled.
Behind the headlines that lay behind these buildings...
...is the fate of the often-indentured construction worker,...
...1.1 million of them.
Mainly Indian, Pakistani, Sri Lankan, and Nepalese, these laborers risk everything...
...to make money for their families back home.
They pay a middleman thousands of dollars to be there.
And when they arrive, they find themselves in labor camps with no water,...
...no air conditioning and their passports taken away.
While it's easy to point the finger at local officials and higher authorities,...
...99 percent of these people are hired by the private sector.
And then the financial collapse happened.
When the contractors had gone bust,...
...as they'd been overleveraged like everyone else,...
...the difference is everything goes missing,...
...documentation, passports, and tickets home for these workers.
Currently right now, thousands of workers are abandoned.
There's no way back home.
And there is no way and no proof of arrival.
These are the boom and bust refugees.
So let's not forget who's really paying the price of this financial collapse.
And that as we worry about our next job in the office,...
...the next design that we can get to keep our workers,...
...let's not forget these men who are truly dying to work.
Thank you.